if you're a river otter in Yellowstone
National Park you're all about finding
new ways to play frolicking in an otter
pile to hollow that's fun but not as
much fun as sliding ice sliding is about
as good as it gets and otter them
sometimes it takes two even three tries
to get a good solid slide a Nutter has
the perfect body for this freeform sport
designed for streamlined swinging its
head and tail taper into a slender body
but they also make the most of that
streamlining on land because they slide
around at every opportunity when they're
frolicking around they seem to always
end up in water these otters have an
amazing fur coat with an inner layer
that traps air keeping frigid water off
their skin and like all extreme sports
enthusiasts are willing to go to great
lengths for the perfect slide and here
it is the perfect slide a group sly
here's a family of otters rollicking
down a mountain size for no other reason
that it's one heck of a lot of fun
these otters can reach speeds as great
as 15 miles an hour on their way to the
bottom
human beings often pay hundreds of
dollars to get into theme parks and go
on rides but aren't any more fun than
this
an otter land is 100% absolutely free